el pasado 6 de enero una turba de
partidarios de donald trump irrumpió en
el capitolio de eeuu facebook condenó el
ataque pero uno de sus científicos de
datos señaló que los algoritmos
utilizados por la compañía jugaron un
papel muy importante en el evento se
trata de francés joven la ex jefa de
producto quien dejó la compañía debido a
los resultados de su investigación
afirmando que algunos de los algoritmos
magnifican el odio y la desinformación
facebook gana más dinero cuando se
consume más contenido la gente disfruta
participando en cosas que consiguen una
reacción emocional cuanto más rabia se
les expone más interactúan y consumen
según la denunciante facebook modificó
los algoritmos antes de las elecciones
de eeuu para hacerlos más seguros pero
los reinicio después de la votación
ignorando los sistemas de seguridad
los datos que publicó muestran que la
empresa ha construido un sistema que
exime a los usuarios verificados de sus
reglas
facebook ha demostrado una y otra vez
que prefiere el beneficio a la seguridad
según la investigación interna que el
joven filtró instagram tiene efectos
peligrosos en los adolescentes más del
13% dice que la red social nos hace
pensar más en el suicidio y el 17%
señala que empeora los trastornos
alimenticios facebook alega que ha
utilizado la mejor tecnología para
frenar el odio que circula en línea
antes de entrevistar a francés joven en
el programa estadounidense de 60 minutos
el vicepresidente de asuntos globales y
comunicaciones de facebook escribió un
memorando a los empleados la evidencia
que existe simplemente no respalda la
idea de que facebook o las redes
sociales en general sean la causa
principal de la polarización
joven testificar ante un subcomité del
senado el martes en una audiencia
titulada proteger a los niños en línea